these three numbers right just I'm just
making them up right I want you to
imagine that what they are our test
scores right so it's like if there was a
test was at 40 and I scored 34 there was
another test it was out 45
I scored 36 and there's a last test out
of 25 and I got 4 wrong so I got 21 okay
so these are three test scores now what
I want you to think about is and argue
with your neighbor which test score do
you think whose best which test score
represents the best performance if I
like three topics which is my best topic
so what I want you to do is I'm gonna
give you about three minutes I want you
to look for yourself trying to come up
with a decision and then I want you to
argue the person next to you see if you
agree or disagree I couldn't have asked
for a more perfect distribution of the
argument between here here now I don't
actually watch it just for the sake of
time I don't want you to articulate what
your reasons are
I just want you to understand like
clearly if you've got like let's just
suppose right of all the people in the
class suppose almost everyone pick this
option and only one person pick this one
or maybe vice versa
okay when you see something like that
that clearly indicates you well most
likely you know everyone is probably in
the majority incorrect and they're just
one message maybe done something wrong
okay
oh well vice versa there's only one
person who really understands and
everyone else has made a critical error
and we don't know which one is yet but
all that I point out to you is that
clearly this is a hard problem to solve
it's tricky and that's why we have so
much disagreement at the moment I just
made up these numbers right and it's
somewhat like in every case which is the
best test score they're all my test
score so it doesn't really matter but
you know what baby
these numbers are more important than
just his scores right maybe they're like
safety ratings for a parachute you have
to decide which one you're gonna take
maybe they're kind of like you know
scores that are on you know people you
want to pick on your sports team and you
know what these little
I have fractions that a difference other
different venues top league and just
kind of second-rate players so these
scores might really matter and comparing
them it's a really important skill no I
established this is a hard question
okay and part of the reason why is
because the language of it is hard I've
don't do this but I'm pretty confident
that everyone in the room give it enough
time even without a calculator could do
that we could work that I would take
some time we do the work here or we can
check with a cafe and read before okay
however I'm going to suggest that if
instead of that I wrote down this I
would probably suggest this question is
almost impossible to do everyone in the
room I'm pretty confident if I asked you
to do this question would have to take
these numbers which I want revenue loss
and you'd have to change them into these
and then you could actually do it like
to try and do it in Rubin your moves by
itself it's like you're just asking for
help so my point here is that the way
you phrase a question the way you
articulate it makes the odd sign the way
you get the answer sometimes very very
difficult or sometimes much much easier
okay sir this question is difficult to
answer because it's all in fractions
some of you have very helpfully said to
me let's get a common denominator okay a
common denominator between 4045 and 25
that thing's gonna be huge right this is
a whole mess to do it even once you
simplify things it's still a bit of a
pain so we're gonna devise a better way
to do this okay I want you underneath
here to make a little something which is
conversion from fractions to now pause I
know you've heard this word before but I
just want to try and
to find for you what we really want is a
common language for all of these numbers
right if there's a way I could say all
of them in the same way so that I can
compare of easily that'd be awesome so
mathematicians design something and they
call them percentages now I know lots of
you have heard percentages before cuz
you've seen the word or you've heard the
word the phrase percent right % % % it's
a Latin phrase what does it actually
mean yeah per hundred out all out of a
hundred because sin is the same word
where we get century a Centurion was a
Roman soldier well remember Romans and
responsive for a hundred soldiers okay
so percent means out of a hundred and
that's why this symbol right out of 100
it has a fraction line in it it has a
fraction line is it but to try and make
it nice and neat instead of writing 100
we write two zeros like that that's
where the percent sign comes from okay
it really means a hundred